avec
avec ce qu'il faut et on a aussi
[Musique]
ça tu vas l'utiliser ou pas
pour les familles nombreuses c'est
génial moi j'en ai qu'un mais même en
ayant qu'un je trouve ça super de
pouvoir partir ça nous fait une journée
pour 4 euros quoi donc franchement c'est
ça vaut vraiment le coup
ça s'adresse à tout le monde en vérité
mais j'irai plus précisément ce sont
pour des gens qui ont pas de problème de
pouvoir d'achat et à qui on offre la
possibilité d'aller sur les plages mais
aussi visiter les cathédrales
l'intérieur
des Hauts de France visiter tous les
lieux remarquables des Hauts de France
pour 1 € aller 1 € retour
[Musique]
sur l'occasion parce que à nouveau comme
on dit c'est pas si cher que ça et même
ça nous permet aussi de bouger un peu
plus prendre un peu l'air et surtout
vous qu'on a pas le permis c'est aussi
le moyen de transport pour y aller nous
on fait ça ça fait depuis 5 ans on en
profite pour
[Musique]